welcome everybody to a very special
episode of the h3 podcast today is my
first ever debate
against the one and only stephen crowder
who it thank you very much thank you
thank you
stephen crowder
who am i to disobey our our great
glorious leader
um crowder challenged me to a debate
he called me a layup he said i
was stupid well stephen
i think the debate speaks for itself
stephen crowder for those of you that
don't know is probably one of the most
hateful bigoted people on the platform
racist homophobic i mean pretty much
hits every box
uh we made this big beautiful
compilation of some of his greatest hits
but it's actually so heinous and
offensive that
youtube uh age restricted the first
upload of our video
so that all is available for our members
the whole with the whole compilation
everything which is you know
adds a lot of atmosphere but for the
sake of this version we had to cut all
that out but
um he is uh let's just take my word for
it in that case a giant douche
well my my tiff with stephen came when
he said that our clip
about covid when we were saying it's
okay to listen to scientists
said it was his favorite clip of all
time we went back and forth for people
who had been following
and stephen boldly challenged me to a
debate
and a video titled your movie thing i
will invite you on the show
uh ethan klein i will have my you know
i'll follow you on twitter i will have
darren my booker reach out where you can
come on this show darren says dad by the
way right
just say your dad bro he keeps trying to
hide that it's his dad you guys will get
more info
about the dad but uh darren's his dad
we usually go after uh political figures
science authoritative sources right on
this show usually those are the people
who we
have to debate change my mind is not a
debate but we've had politicians
scientists pulitzer winners uh and every
now and then
a layup crosses our our path who we you
know we just
just kind of like the stick that you're
only capable of now in our original
video
about crowder we had noticed that he had
reached out to me
to book me on his show and he was kind
of but her
that i ghosted him all this time and in
this video he claims here that he never
reached out to a booker and that
that i'm lying about it so here's what
he says about that
i'm going to assume that you didn't
blatantly lie in some of the things that
you said that you're just
really lazy or incapable of your due
diligence so you said some
we'll get to female booker reached out
to you for the show hey gerald have i
ever had a female booker uh that's
that's a no
never now you're either lying we don't
work with women on this show
so that's impossible or you're so
ig lazy because i don't want to bully
you and then you go and try and get a
swoop
you're so lazy you didn't even just
verify the fact that it was complete
well i
you know what i actually i took this to
heart so i said you know what stephen i
am going to
look into this i found the email that
was sent to me was very professional
um and it still had her social media
contacts on it
and so i followed her down on instagram
and i said hey
blank did you ever do booking for louder
with crowder i'm just trying to verify
that this email i got from you
invited me on the show is real or not
thanks here's the email by the way super
professional definitely a real email
by the way uh this one in particular she
immediately responded to me she said
yes i did booking for him years ago for
a few months i'm not quite sure whose
contact you'd have now i know his dad
does his booking for him though
let me know if you need to try his
finest contact interesting that she
knows that detail that makes me think
that is
very real and that he's lying about
inviting me on his show how odd
well yeah and and while we're talking
about lying stephen why don't you tell
them that you never filed a lawsuit
tell tell us if you filed that lawsuit
against youtube stephen come on be
honest with your
viewers and you know stephen says he
doesn't want to bully me but here he
goes on to say this and i am very and i
am feeling
very insecure now that steven is taking
a shot at me
wait the kleenex let me just say first
of all
you have about a second we were making
fun of the fact that stephen had
kleenex on his table which is pretty
funny let's be honest he's seen there
with gun holsters and tissue i mean what
is he crying every second
so listen to this that's due to
allergies okay
uh so i had a bronchial thing which is
community guidelines in immutable
condition it's genetic
oh poor steven with his allergies don't
put the tissue on your desk
it's funny all right don't get so
twisted up look how twisted he gets
about me laughing about him crying all
the time he needs a box of tissue on his
desk
but i guess there's a cease fire here so
we can talk about any genetic conditions
like the lack of chin
lack of beard 120 pound man wearing the
cinderelly bandana on his head
one i didn't get what's the 120 plummet
cinderella
i i don't i couldn't really he's talking
about me i'm i'm
i'm i am not 120 pound trust me dude
we don't right
well anyway and to compensate with the
beard that he uses just for men or the
phrase like et in the cornfield it's so
stupid bro
the point is i always think it's like
hilarious when people debat
actually go to the debase themselves to
making fun of my tourette's
you know it's like okay dude and i
really got you hard with the tissue
thing bro
just don't you think you i can't hide my
tourette you fired the first volley by
making fun of his allergies your
allergies dude
[Music]
you didn't have a disability yeah we
didn't realize
he had a disability like that yeah i'm
so sorry bro ableist
i had all that coming yeah
i'm deeply offended though at the
bullying uh portrayed and i
take absolute cross with that you know
and dan had this one moment that
actually went a little bit viral in the
political community that stephen notably
ignored during our tit for tat i'll play
it for you here
and this is where i'm leading a lot of
people but just because i feel like
there's a decent chance stephen crowder
will see this and
this will be the only time that i get to
say this debate sam cedar dude stop
being such a [ __ ]
i know that your dad doesn't want you to
uh and
you know but that was a long time ago
that was three you're three years older
now
it's time it's time to debate sam
ah and notably he doesn't include this
he watches the whole clip
but not the debate sam cedar weird he
didn't cover that part
he went into a lot of detail on
everything else oh yeah oh exhaustive
detail
now who is sam cedar sam cedar is the
host of a political
left-leaning show called the majority
report
has a million subs he's a big channel
crowder
famously backed out of a scheduled
debate
with sam at politicon earning him the
name
cold feet crowder at the behest of his
dad
sam secretly recorded the phone call
with the organizer of the event who
exposed crowder here's the call
yeah that's a real shame i think you're
about you're bigger
yeah i i don't know what his
team is doing around him and that's you
know just for me to speculate
at this point um he i don't know
he has a team he has a whole team and he
won't do it he could bring the team
i believe it's his father but i can't
confirm or deny that
by the way everyone seems to be
affirming that it's his dad doing all
this [ __ ] behind the scenes somehow
so people speculate that actually
he actually backed out of the debate
because sam is actually
you know an informed good debater
and they were afraid that you know
crowder would look like an idiot
and so he backed out at the last minute
at the behest of his father
the thing is he's happy to challenge me
somebody that
has no political no very little i don't
spend my day
talking and thinking about politics nor
am i a debater
nor am i let's be honest intelligent
sophie right let's be honest so with all
that being said
we figured let's get someone who is
familiar with the topics who does
spend their time thinking about politics
and who is you know unlike me
smart so we've got a little surprise
for stephen crowder so let's all enjoy
the debate
i'm really glad to have my next guest on
the show and i've always said this i
always respect people who um
enter the enter into the arena um and
you know we've had a lot of debates on
this show which is different from like
it changed my mind where we sit down
with conversations
but uh mile brazilian jiu jitsu coach
said if you come a switch
we go switch you go spicy we're going to
do a little spicy
so we're always trying to keep it as
respectful as possible and i really do
appreciate the guy making the time
because a lot of people haven't
has a huge youtube channel several
youtube channels one of the ogs
a lot of people watch them uh you know
some of you like them some of you don't
same can be said for me ethan klein from
h3h3 uh ethan thank you thanks man for
making the time
you're very welcome and i just want to
say i know you called me you said that i
would be a layup
yeah because i don't think i'm a very
good debater
i think you know that so uh i didn't
want to make it too easy for you
oh okay so uh i've prepared
okay yes all right so what we're going
to talk about
is uh what we were going to talk about
is you know the initial quote that
happened
i think he's looking off there uh the
initial quote that kind of was turned
into
um a little bit uh of a meme which
wasn't intentional
and uh was you saying you don't even
have to think about it
regarding the cdc uh and i disagree with
that
um i think people should think about it
i believe and we
said talked about this through playful
ribbing in an aggregation of medical
authorities and scientific
voices to make an informed and rational
decision um
so where do you think that i was that
i'm wrong on that
stephen do you know that um the spartans
are
that they are like uh practice man love
with children
oh jeez okay so this is what's gonna
happen i told what did i tell you he was
gonna do anything he could to avoid
oh oh there he is oh no sam cedar what a
what what a [ __ ] nightmare
i had no idea this was going to happen i
thought i thought ethan was a stand-up
guy
this is where we are yeah i thought dave
dave remember i told you i told you
i said this i guarantee you he's going
to do anything he can to avoid the
debate i just think he believes that he
should debate you
no no he doesn't he just takes advantage
of of women with you know mental health
issues
incline doesn't stand up and do his own
fight
right let's play on fm you
would uh do anything to avoid talking to
me i think you're
the point that you mentioned
and jordan peterson and noam chomsky and
sam harris everyone's been avoiding
not just attention to your audience by
jumping in
well i
that you were taking your show off early
last time coming in today with your
pig pen peanuts i wish everything
you take those off for the velveteen
buttons
stephen i don't know why no one would be
worried about it
you shouldn't want to do it
ethan you should be yourself
stop showing your little leprechaun
co-host who comes out dressed like
your sidekick ethan why do you have to
bring it
let me hear what let me hear what pig
pen has to say here really quick fair
enough
but ethan ethan look i don't hold on a
second ethan that's because
i came here to talk with ethan ethan
come on man look
the same reason that i haven't ever had
a conversation with sam cedars the same
reason that uh joe rogan
uh sam harris brett weinstein dave rubin
ben shapiro don't own anything it's
based on a lie
ethan just like you claiming
sam why do you feel that anyone owes you
airtime when you have a 40th of the
audience and you've been doing this show
i don't think anybody ten times
i think i think that ethan has just
given it to me
i didn't ask him for it and so you've
been begging
your audience cares that i only have a
million subscribers and you have what
six or seven million subscribers let me
answer can i answer your question
can i answer your question can i answer
your question you want me to answer your
question
my audience would say sam who just like
joe rogan's audience and ben shapiro's
and dave reuben who i am
now they were just who you are because
you had to shoot on yourself
every day that you do that yeah
let me clarify sam let me clarify the
change in my mind everyone knows on the
show right we've had professors
i ended my show last week stephen if
your audience because you're an
idiot and half of your staff doesn't
like yourself because i'm a die-hard fan
yes it's because
it's a die-hard fan of you
but i just met you why not
congratulations
right now i'm trying to talk with you
you're interrupting someone started the
show
you bombarded you bombarded my show
under a false pretense
you claimed that ever just like you
claimed that i ducked the debate with
you under a false pretense
that is what the politicon people told
me what they told you
so you're just lazy with your research
and if not
what if you continue with the lie you
need to research
did stephen ever accept they said you
were let me let me explain to you let me
explain to you let me explain
hey
sam fake stand-up comic who we can't
find any footage about online let me
stand up comic oh you're not okay that
makes sense because
everything that i've seen is incredibly
unfunny and unentertaining
the
sam samuel can i answer your question
yes
so you have gone on you've done the same
thing with other other comments everyone
has a bigger audience than you
because you said i want to speak with
stephen crowder
you believe that at some point there was
some acceptance when have i ever done a
politicon
ever as a matter of fact in the last
in the last decade i haven't done a
single political conference i hosted
cpac for four years and stopped because
they suck
they don't pay and they're full of
losers and you've been clamoring
for it told me that you dropped
so ethan do you want to have a
conversation
remember we said hold on a second hold
on a second
never even allows a shadow of comedy to
be perceived on his program it was
hiding
everything we do is out in the open h3
h3
when you're wearing the whole we agreed
so hold on a second yeah
so i want to normalize responsible gun
ownership is that your debate no wonder
you had to bring in a hack for you're
talking about comedy
all right sam you you you got it you got
it i hope you haven't
given it hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on let me just make one
point hope you enjoy politico hold on
let me make one take it easy
if you have the velveteen rabbit buttons
that's the only thing i'm curious about
it's
all right good you guys are good thank
you don't even take off the glasses oh
it's right
all right you run away twice
cold feet again come on stephen
wow
wow dude i can't believe he admit to the
following
he admitted that he followed the show
last week we got
him admitted that he watched the show we
got him
dude we played him so hard because he
he literally was following he saw that
you went live dude we [ __ ] got him
oh my god we [ __ ] nailed him
holy [ __ ] so do you want to respond to
here you want to throw him up dan
do you want to respond to anything he
said now that he's not talking over you
um well i mean look uh he's obviously
lying about the idea that he wouldn't
want to do uh
do a debate with me because his audience
wouldn't know
here's a guy who literally tracked my
show last week
because he was afraid that this would
happen he is
here's a guy who uh claims to have
watched i don't know
i don't know what it is he said he
watched but he's not worried about
audience not knowing who he's debating
because he sits down with
random college kids and sandbags them
on uh their campus he
i have the recording from politicon when
they called and he backed out
i have emails from gavin mcginnis whose
show
i would have never gone on except he
offered up a debate with
crowder and crowder left and so you know
i
think stephen is afraid of debating
somebody you know look i do a political
show every day
it's true i don't it's boring you don't
yeah exactly
and so if he wants to debate the issues
what's the difference
between me and anybody in the world
i i mean only that he is convinced that
for whatever reason he's nervous about
debating me i don't know why i don't
know why that's the case but i debated
charlie kirk
at politicon it was fine i thought kirk
did a fairly good job
i think steven's not a total idiot but i
also do think he's a bit of a liar
i mean yeah we even went through the
effort of tracking down this claim that
he never booked us for the show
i mean here's the email super
professional so i was like i definitely
i reached out to the girl she said um i
said did you send me this email she said
yes i did years ago for a few months i
worked for stephen crowder
booking i'm not quite sure who you'd
contact now i know his dad
does the booking for him let me know if
you need
me to try to find you how would she know
that if she didn't work for them
you know what's funny is that when the
politicon
um when the the woman from politicon
called me
she also mentioned that his dad he
she said his team i think stephen got
cold feet his team pulled him out
and i said wait he's got a team and he
said well his dad
right and you know i mean i
i i called my dad to see if he could
call steven's dad
to see if stephen would debate me like
on some
type of playdate but my father said
reminded me that i was a grown man and i
should probably handle it myself oh you
know that's funny my dad is actually
zooming with his dad later today to
debate this very topics
you know what else he lied about uh
filing this lawsuit he there's no
lawsuit he ever filed
at least that i can find in the public
record which lawsuits are a public
record
uh so he had he is a liar as far you
know uh
the evidence does does suggest yeah and
the thing is is that you know
they go on and on about getting
demonetized from youtube or whatever it
is
and uh they never for them it's really
just a
a way of generating clicks there are oh
yes the same way
yeah i mean there are policies that you
could pursue but he can't ever address
those because his ideology
is such that there's no way
for for him to address it as a policy
matter
so because as a policy matter he'd have
to agree that there needs to be
government regulation of these things
and he doesn't believe in government
regulation and so uh he just goes out
there and makes it as if it's like uh
conservatives are somehow being
oppressed
as well that's not it's actually not
true at all everybody who talks about
these issues
if they're taking a conservative or
liberal stance on them are
they're all getting demonetized equally
the fact that oh yeah
the fact that stephen wants to go out
there and do a mock execution of george
floyd and then act bewildered when his
channel gets uh
when his videos get demonetized cool
it's quite surprising to me that he
would even be
feigned surprised at that yeah we get i
don't know i don't i don't know how what
our percentage of d monetization is for
our videos if it happens we just don't
whine about it like they do and use it
to generate clicks it's because
we're willing to talk about topics that
we know i mean we don't do
[ __ ] like what uh crowder does that that
are just out and out racist
and and homophobic but we will we will
talk about protests we will talk about
um
you know political situations that
advertisers don't want to be a part of
absolutely that's just part of doing the
job responsibly is understanding
you're not gonna be able to suck a
dollar out of every single uh bit of
content
if you're actually you know trying to uh
you know make a point about issues
and one other thing he keeps bringing up
apparently the reason he's ducked you
sam is because you only have
one million subscribers i know it
and i i've actually challenged somebody
to go through all the interviews he's
done
and find any with under a million
because that would be quite ironic
yeah i find it hard to believe that
stephen has that metric particularly
since
half of his you know all of his change
my minds are with college students
who may not even have a youtube channel
right you have more subs than them
surely at least a couple more than that
yeah
well i feel we got him pretty good here
sam
well you know i would have liked to had
an exchange of ideas with stephen so
i'm a little bit disappointed and i know
how much you were looking forward to
that too
uh you know weird uh but i guess steven
is just
more interested in personalities than he
is uh
actually debating issues yeah it's sort
of sad it is
that because he claims he's a political
thinker but
he doesn't think he didn't think much in
this case uh
i gotta wonder if there are members of
his audience right now who are probably
thinking like hey wait
a second maybe stephen is actually
afraid of having some type of exchange
i mean he spent how many times did he
say in the preface of of going on air
with you
you know a lot of times people won't
show up for debates with me
and here we are baby he only wants to
debate
um you know people who have a
perspective on the left that have a a
youtube channel that's over a million
well maybe you've got to expand your
harassment
maybe you should be looking to debate
people who are actually proficient
in debating and the topics itself
instead of
he referred to me as a layup and i would
agree with him in that i'm not
politically savvy
and i'm not a debater so what so what
what actual uh
value is there and debating me for him
other than for him to look smart and get
an easy
point exactly but but let me say this
that the
original points that you were making
about when it came to like the masks
um i uh i've interviewed
i don't know uh half a dozen different
epidemiologists maybe a little bit more
over the past year
uh on the show uh some of the top
epidemiologists in the country
and the fact of the matter is is that
there was uh confusion and really
not uh the science was not settled on
the way that covid was was transferred
they didn't realize that it could be
aerosized but the bottom line is is that
wearing masks once they understood this
where the downside to wearing masks is
zero well yeah according to steven
scientists are not ever allowed to
change their mind
see uh scientists need to be right the
first time and only the first time
they're not allowed to change their
stance with data and research
and if they do then they're frauds
forever for everything
i mean i even saw stephen talking about
oh uh fauci was wrong about aids back in
you know that what was it the uh
the early 80s and that's proof right he
is he felt she was wrong
sometime previously in his career uh so
therefore
he is a fraud forever i speaking of
fraud i noticed that uh
that uh crowder put up a an email you
know making a big deal about these
emails from fauci and one of them he put
up was from february 12th
where fauci was saying we don't think
masks for the general public is going to
be that effective or make a point which
is what he said publicly
which is what he said publicly a month
later but the fact is
that the the development of the science
behind aero
aerosolization of the virus
was an ongoing ever wasn't until like
you know uh
late april that they started to realize
this is the way it's going through there
and then they
don't it's not easy to to take a novel
new coronavirus and assess like what are
the size of the particles
but the bottom line is once they said do
masks it is an
easy lift to wear a mask it sucks
but it was the safest thing to do and
i'm sitting here with it with a study
i mean they're really starting to come
out now
that the masks cut down
by anywhere from 25 to 35 percent
on the transmission and so
the idea that there are some scientists
he talks about aggregating the science
look he doesn't know how to agree he's
afraid to debate me
and i only you know a guy with a million
subscribers on youtube
he's he's not aggregating the science
there are professionals
who aggregate the science sam do you
think that the size of your sub count is
a
a
is a is there a correlation to to your
uh
your skills as a debater that seems to
be what crowders understanding is
apparently yeah or it's just that he he
is looking for any
excuse as to why he doesn't want to have
a conversation with somebody
who actually you know day in and day out
reads this stuff
and talks to uh scientists and talks to
reporters
i mean look you can find a lot of people
who will say the earth is flat and if i
aggregate those
into all the scientists who say the
earth is in fact not flat
then you could say there's some
questions but but that's not the way
that science works
the fact of the matter is is that like
we have a
basic understanding of what what's going
on
and the idea of you saying listen to the
scientists
particularly addressing youtube
guys yeah when you're stephen crowder
thank you yeah so obviously
our whole little battle came when
stephen stephen
said it's his favorite clip of the year
of us saying
listen if you're like uh
you know lis it's okay to listen to to
scientists
who are trying to save it's okay you
don't need to question
every single thing that comes across
especially if you have no qualifications
at all to assess this information the
fact that we
need to be skeptical of every single
thing of our government that we don't
trust our government to to that extent
then then
our society has failed us in in a way
that we should just
end it now but i you know i think like
you can be skeptical but the fact of the
matter
is is that what crowder is not doing
he's not being skeptical in any type of
thoughtful way
he is weaponizing doubts that happen to
align with his political ideology
we saw it with the president that he was
so supportive of
i mean uh you know you can it's not hard
to find many clips of trump saying this
is just gonna go away it's not really
serious there's only a couple of cases
we shouldn't even test right and crowder
that's why crowder was doing it i mean
if it was
if he was doing a genuinely
skeptical you know sort of like uh
categorization and cataloging
of the science and laying it out there
in a way that showed
some measure of integrity but let's
let's be honest i mean
people just watch this crowder had the
opportunity to debate this with somebody
who is
who is serious about it and wanted to
debate with him i did nothing but you
know approach this with a respectful
manner
and he was afraid to do that because he
knows he's full of it
and he's just delivering talking points
that
you know uh his nra buddies you know
give him to go
they all it's all it's all part of the
big griff that all these conservative
media
it's like you said it's like uh they
suck every dollar
out of every controversy and that's all
that matters to him because you know
he's got these big beautiful leather
holsters
and those things don't fill themselves
you know
and um and you know it it is worth
mentioning
once again that he noticed that you
ended your show early last week
and we we specifically were like i know
he's watching because he's so afraid of
sam
that we need to pre-record something air
it
so that he thinks you're live right
right and it works
as we are talking there is a live show
and he came out we started the show two
minutes early
and he did not walk on to the set until
our show was live so true and and you
call
i gotta say you called it last week and
i was like
i can't i just don't believe that he's
that nervous
about i can't believe he admitted
dumbass and
also like the alternative is
i think that sam could show up and i
can't wait to show my audience
how this [ __ ] who's been dogging me
supposedly
and sending people to you know debate
me and this and that i'm gonna put this
to rest once and for all
if stephen crowder was as much of a man
as he seems to
to be with his you know all his
weightlifting
and his gun and his holster he's got
he's got a weapon for god's sakes
yeah i'm coming unarmed hands up if you
want to shoot go ahead how much
alpha brain do you think he takes in the
morning
he's probably juicing and the idea
that he had at least a week in advance
knowledge that he couldn't come prepared
to debate
somebody who actually reads this stuff
and spends
their time doing this is is almost like
the saddest thing that one could say
about stephen crowder yeah
almost i'm sure there's some other
things oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
wow stephen
it's really sad i mean i was looking
forward to it because i really wanted
irony right as you've pointed out is
that he's the guy who got famous for
with the debate me he you can't
if you're the debate me guy that's your
claim to fame
you can't dodge people that want to
debate you stephen you gotta own this
thing that you create this image you
created stop being a [ __ ] stop being a
baby you're
like come on stephen i think he lost the
right to the to those holsters i think
he has to retire them
honestly yeah i think i'm calling on
retiring those holsters
today uh normalize wearing a squirt gun
instead is what i would say to him you'd
have to or maybe like a nerf
they have to have like a nerf weapon
like is he old enough to now
like have a license for a handgun or he
doesn't need to anymore
yeah i mean i think honestly like i
think we should need to have a meeting
with his dad
and yeah i have a brilliant father i'll
be
maybe we should email him just say you
know we think that i don't know if his
dad will be answering any of my emails
after today after today we're gonna have
to ask for his uh badge and uh
weapon we're both fathers
i i can't tell you how disappointed i
would be in my son
if he did what stephen did oh so
disappointed son
yeah outside i i just uh
my son had his final uh uh pony league
baseball game yesterday
and i saw more courage from some of
those eight-year-olds
uh than we witnessed from stephen
crowder today i mean i would say
probably like
like a good three or four of them were a
lot tougher than crowder one guy hit
the ball the other one like uh tripped
yeah oh that's one of them didn't have
their favorite hat
but they all played through it right
they all played through
sad that that did steven did you find it
interesting to how he wouldn't put the
camera on him for a minute
it was just on his sidekick yeah what do
you think was going on do you think he
was like
like going like ah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
get god in here yeah
but i'm glad he finally brought it back
because i was like what is with the
sidekick why are you throwing him under
the bus
i know it and the sidekick had to
pretend like he was a big fan of mine
he had to come in real quick monitoring
the show that is
his psychic wasn't even drunk yet it is
early usually that guy's pissed drunk by
the time they do their show is i you
know to be honest like i have
the only time i think i've watched a uh
an extended run of crowder show was when
he was talking about
you i was trying to figure out like how
how did this start and
he was really drippily condescending for
a guy who
is afraid to actually test
his his his beliefs yeah uh i mean i'm
i'm surprised
i haven't seen him so weak since
watching him get punched in the face and
dropping
like a deck like a house of cards by an
old man wisconsin
oh that's the other thing i don't know
if you knew this so
crowder when he was complaining about
what happened
on youtube to him you know like he put
out a compilation video
of people responding to when he got
decked by a union guy
in wisconsin at the uh 2011
uh march protests against scott walker
and
in that compilation i was in it
and put the video out and then he pulled
it back and cut me out of the
compilation
and reposted it on twitter do we have
that stuff
oh wow he you he is deathly afraid of
you
it is uh uh we somebody on twitter saw
it and said
and we did a video about it but he is it
is weird
deathly afraid and how he
pretends that's the thing i don't get
like how do you spend so much time
worrying about somebody that you think
is not big enough
to even like discuss who is he supposed
to debate then
if not you i don't know yeah me
i'm not a political debater i'm just
some dumb ass
yeah i mean i i i don't know i
maybe he's trolling through to find like
you know like a makeup
tutorial sites that have like two
million
subscribers or i mean
uh anybody who doesn't craft those i
have a lot of subs
exactly yeah there's some minecrafters
my son watches that
um that uh that that that maybe he'd
like to debate
on some of these issues right
wow all right well we got him dude yeah
that was fun
i appreciate your you're attempting to
to further the discourse ethan
and that's all i care about in the end
of the day i just wanted to put forward
the best conversation possible
to inform the most people possible but
stephen today wasn't able to do that for
us
i know it's so sad it's a disappointment
you gave him the opportunity
and i hope his dad does have a stern
talking to like son
this is the way to behave this is the
this was not the proper way to behave in
this situation
and gives him a good fatherly talk
there's been times where i've said to my
son
we're going to call up blankety blank's
dad her mom and you're gonna you're
gonna get on the phone and you're gonna
apologize
and so i just want to say i
i'm sure i don't want to speak for you
but we'll be very gracious
when steven's dad calls and puts it on
the phone when someone apologizes
you you you you accept that
you know because i want to make that
absolutely clear that
if um stephen calls to apologize i'm
going to be gracious about it yeah
that's funny
you just reminded me he kept telling me
um he kept telling me
i respect anyone that enters the ring
and i'll make my fans known of that i'm
it's very i i respect that you're
willing to enter the ring with me
and uh apparently he doesn't respect
that about you
no i guess not you don't have enough
subscribers i don't have enough
subscribers to earn the respect to enter
the ring when you enter the ring a
million
do so i'd like to know where at what
point
you are capable of entering the ring uh
and well what's the subscriber threshold
because the first time
the first time he made this argument i
only had i think 500 000 subscribers
and then uh and then i feel like it's
there's
the goal posts are like he's dragging
them with him as he runs along uh down
the field
and they're just getting further and
further yeah i mean i'll try to get more
intel on that for you
i appreciate that i appreciate that and
you know maybe uh folks can
you know uh you know reach out to him on
twitter and ask him politely
you know uh you know how far are the
goal posts
yeah let's let's find out so that we can
have something to
work towards right so if you can ask
steven
how many subs does sam need to be worthy
of the
the big stage because i'll stick at it
just to hit that number um well we could
buy you subs or you know we can work
something out
yeah we could just buy the subs that
really occurred to me but yeah
i should have done that i should have
done that today i should have bought a
really deal stephen uh give me a minute
um all right well uh i've got to uh
my show uh the the uh pre-record is
going to end
in about 20 minutes uh the one that is
there
almost exclusively for stephen and his
dad
and it worked there they watched it
amazing
amazing that he admit that
smart guy he really shouldn't have said
that that was probably
the biggest mistake he made oh yeah
oh my god and then the second one was
coming after me
yeah yeah that that was probably the
first mistake he made and then there
were subsidiary mistakes
that followed all right sam ethan it was
a pleasure i can't
uh thank you enough for the opportunity
i'm sorry yeah this was a great time
yeah
apologies to stephen and his dad for
yeah me too you know
just feel well all right all right have
a good day bye
you too